mes chers amis
je suis très heureux d'être ici une
nouvelle fois pour la dixième fois comme
beaucoup d'entre vous je crois que mot
de l'a dit ici fidèle à Guidel
malgré le beau temps
et je voudrais commencer par des
remerciements alors je ne serai pas
aussi précis que l'a été mode mais la
livraison de le faire je voudrais
adresser des remerciements au bénévoles
aux équipes du siège sous la houlette et
de mode et d'Anne Caroline et Gina mais
je ne ferai pas l'ensemble de la liste
tous ceux qui depuis des années avec
patience avec minutie avec beaucoup de
bienveillance avec chacun d'entre nous
font en sorte que les choses se passent
dans les meilleures conditions et c'est
aussi ça la réussite de Guidel c'est une
équipe qui depuis 10 ans est restée
fidèle quand parfois d'autres chemins
professionnels sont ouverts ils sont
revenus toujours à Guidel parce que
c'est un moment à la vérité un peu
familiale et dont je voudrais saluer
toutes celles et ceux les responsables
aussi que vous êtes les responsables de
départements pour assurer une
mobilisation très forte François le
disait d'ailleurs depuis jeudi ou
vendredi c'est nous sommes à nous très
important cette année ça montre aussi la
force à la fois de ce que nous sommes et
la force aussi de la capacité que nous
avons à attirer les gens vers nous je
voudrais saluer
les collègues ministres Sarah Geneviève
que j'ai sous les yeux et Jean-Noël qui
est un peu en campagne et c'est un peu
iconoclaste mais il est un peu en
campagne et donc je salue à travers mes
paroles la campagne qu'il fait pour
reconquérir son siège de député et puis
j'aurai saluer le président de notre
groupe
Jean-Paul Mathy alors c'est quelque
chose d'assez bizarre parce que je
mode parlent et elle est secrétaire
général je le fus Jean-Paul a parlé il
est Président je vous voyais où on peut
arriver à la fin c'est juste pour vous
dire que tous les chemins je ne sais pas
où il mène s'il menthe Rome mais en tout
cas il peut arriver des tas de choses
tenez vous prêt je le dirai à la fin
d'ailleurs on sait jamais ce qui peut
arriver dans la vie et puis je vous
laisse saluer je le dirai un mot tout à
l'heure toutes celles et ceux qui depuis
des années sont avec nous vous les
militants vous les parlementaires vous
les cadres et qui faisons en sorte que
les choses fonctionnent je voudrais dire
que après 10 ans ce qui est intéressant
ce que je voulais vous dire c'est que
finalement pourquoi on est là la
première chose c'est parce qu'en fait on
n'a jamais renoncé
on a toujours fait le choix de
l'indépendance et des convictions 2012
c'était un choix audacieux c'était un
choix difficile François me regarde en
souriant il voit de quoi je veux je veux
parler et vous avez été nombreux à
l'époque à être là dès 2012 notre était
arrivé avant en disant que c'était un
choix audacieux et difficile parce que
nous avions fait le choix qui est pas
difficile celui des convictions et de
l'indépendance qui était le plus évident
mais qui n'est jamais un choix facile
dans la vie politique et je vous
remercier toutes celles et ceux qui
depuis 2012 et avant ont suivi ce choix
mais à la vérité le choix de 2012 il
était la continuité de ce que j'avais
perçu chez François quand je me suis
engagé dans ce mouvement parce qu'il y
avait eu des épisodes précédents il y
avait eu des européennes en 99 et en
2004 il y avait eu des régionales en
2004 et en 2010 il y avait une
présidentielle en 2002 et en 2007 et à
la vérité 2012 un n'était que la
bourtissement pour ceux qui ne l'avaient
pas vu de l'exercice plein et entier de
la liberté d'une famille politique et
c'est au rendez-vous que nous sommes
depuis 10 ans mais pas depuis 10 ans
depuis 25 ans que je suis dans ce parti
c'est à ce rendez-vous là qui est celui
de ne jamais avoir renoncé parce que
dans la politique quand on renonce on
renonce à l'essentiel de la politique me
semble-t-il et voilà ce que je voulais
saluer aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
et dans la capacité à ne pas renoncer il
y a la capacité à mener des combats
je ne suis pas en reste mais beaucoup
dans cette salle ne sont pas en reste
des combats et je voudrais saluer celles
et ceux qui depuis des années même des
combats électoraux pour porter ce que
nous sommes pour porter nos idées pour
porter notre indépendance parfois ou
pour la réaffirmer quand il est besoin
de le faire et je voudrais évidemment en
premier chef salut et Patrick qui m'a
succédé au groupe qui a mené des combats
à peu près dans la même temporalité que
moi peut-être même un petit peu avant
dans d'autres sphères mais qui n'étaient
pas éloignées à l'époque déjà et saluer
toutes celles et ceux qui autour de lui
Bruno Silvain Marguerite Michel Jean-Luc
Nadia Christophe et tous ceux qui sont
allés au combat qui avait été au combat
depuis très longtemps et qui ont été
avec nous en 2017 qui ne sont plus
aujourd'hui mais qui sont avec nous
aujourd'hui et donc le sens des combats
c'est aussi ça
je voudrais saluer le combat de ceux qui
ont été élus et puis ce saluer le combat
de ceux qui ont été battus et qui ont
porté une nouvelle fois nos couleurs en
2022 et puis saluer le combat qui est
parfois le plus difficile c'est ceux qui
n'ont pas pu mener le combat
ceux qui ont parce que nous avons décidé
de construire une alliance
accepter qu'ils se mettent au service
parfois de candidature alors que
eux-mêmes étaient candidat et je sais
pour les responsables de mouvement que
vous êtes comme ça peut être difficile
alors qu'on porte de combat de ne pas
pouvoir soi-même le porter mais à la
vérité nous portions un combat collectif
et donc Jean-Paul maintenant tu as la
lourde charge on en parlait l'autre soir
de de présider à un groupe mais que tu
ne connais parfaitement je sais ton
talent à la fois de négociateur et ta
capacité de fermeté parce que quand on
est président de groupe j'en ai deux
sous les yeux mais François connaît
aussi c'est capacité particulière et
avec grandes diplomaties avec les siens
et grande diplomatie avec les autres et
c'est un amendement particulièrement
mais je pense que c'est un moment
particulièrement heureux tous ceux qui
en sont sortis restent avec un bon
souvenir tu viens d'y rentrer donc
j'imagine que les choses se passeront au
mieux avec l'ensemble des troupes parce
que je viendrai après tout ça n'a pas
été possible et cette ce non-renancement
il est lié aussi au fait ce que vous on
a dans le groupe et ce qu'on a aussi
dans le mouvement c'est qu'on n'a jamais
non plus fait défauts à l'esprit de
solidarité et d'unité
et je vous le dis dans les familles
politiques que nous avons autour de nous
globalement dans leurs histoires elles
se sont toujours fracassées sur l'esprit
de solidarité sur l'esprit d'unité et
nous avons été unis à la fois dans les
défaites
dans les difficultés dans les combats
que nous avons eu amener et c'est plus
difficile encore d'être unis et de faire
preuve de solidarité quand on est dans
les phases de victoire et donc je
voudrais saluer toutes celles et ceux
qui œuvrent qui pensent que rien n'est
jamais acquis ni la victoire ni la
défaite et qui font que ça c'est une
marque de solidarité et d'unité qui est
très précieuse dans la vie politique et
qui nous permet de voyager depuis un
certain nombre d'années bravo à tous de
cela aussi
la troisième chose la troisième chose
que je voulais dire tout ça ne serait
pas possible et nous ne serions pas au
rendez-vous si nous n'avions pas une
profonde capacité d'ouverture et
d'accueil
alors Auguste tu disais
nous sommes les dépositaires nous sommes
à la fois les dépositaires et en même
temps nous sommes ceux qui pensent que
d'autres peuvent venir enrichir cette
famille politique en permanence
et c'est ça la force de ce mouvement et
ça me permet de saluer ce que je connais
depuis
quelques paires d'années et ce que je
vois arriver encore aujourd'hui parce
qu'un mouvement qui n'est pas capable en
permanence d'accueillir de nouveaux
profils c'est un mouvement qui à terme
peut disparaître et ne la force et la
nôtre c'est notre capacité d'ouverture
et j'en dirai un mot juste après vous
dire un mot aussi des temps que nous
traversons aux mots d'en parler elle
aussi des temps qui paraissent un peu
sombre quand on réfléchit en trois ans
on a belié à peu près ce que sont les
grandes peurs millénaires ou multi
millénaires ou multi séculaire comme
vous voulez
la peur de l'épidémie
la peur de la guerre
et dans certains coins du continent du
globe la peur de la famille et nous
sommes dans une période donc il faut
mesurer la force sur les peuples et les
risques que ça peut produire comme nous
sommes sur des peurs de cette nature là
qui sont pas des peurs irréelles qui
sont des peurs que les gens ont vécu et
en 3 ans covid et la suite des
événements avec la guerre en Ukraine on
a renoué avec les peurs et donc nous
sommes dans des temps compliqués des
temps compliqué qui le président de la
République a dit je trouve avec grande
justesse quand il avait perdu la fin de
l'innocence ou de la fin de
l'insouciance sans doute la fin de
l'innocence
et la fin de l'insouciance je vois que
Jimmy me dit il y a l'abondance mais j'y
viens après mais nous étions dans un
territoire dans un espace et même dans
un monde où nous pensions que les choses
étaient désormais acquises et que le
monde et que certains professionnels la
fin de l'histoire
il y a pas si longtemps que ça et nous
renouer avec des moments historiques il
y avait l'histoire et c'est ça aussi la
fin de l'innocence et de l'inconscience
ou de l'insouciance que nous avions et
nous avons besoin de retrouver quelque
chose dans un monde d'occidental qui
était un monde dominant qui croyait que
ça pensait son modèle économique sa
pensée philosophique était dominante
Jean-Yves Le Drian le disait hier et
nous avons besoin de renouer aussi nous
avec une force qui permette dans le
cadre qui est le nôtre de retrouver la
fierté de ce que nous sommes et de
repenser le monde différemment de ce
qu'il était ce qui s’écoute la façon
dont il s'est construit depuis 70 ans et
puis nous vivons le monde aussi de
l'intolérance
et l'intolérance elle n'est pas qu'à
l'extérieur de nos frontières la
violence elle n'est pas qu'à l'extérieur
de nos frontières et il me semble que
ces temps-là sont des temps qui sont
difficiles les gens diraient un mot
quasiment en conclusion il me semble que
c'est là-dessus aussi que nous devons
nous devons ouvrir et François parler
hier ou avant-hier je ne sais plus des
questions de réconciliation nous avons
besoin dans ces temps d'intolérance dans
ces temps de grands bouleversements
d'essayer de reconcilier les gens avec
eux-mêmes mais de réconcilier les gens
avec le monde dans lesquels ils vivent
il me semble que c'est un élément
important alors je vous ai pas parlé
beaucoup d'agriculture parce que tel
n'est pas l'objet de mon discours elle
avait été quand vous êtes au poste de
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire
vous avez face à vous les mêmes sujets
les sujets mondiaux les sujets européens
les sujets nationaux vous avez face à
vous les sujets de la liberté par
rapport à la souveraineté alimentaire
vous avez les sujets du dérèglement
climatique et qui remontent en cause
profondément
non seulement les activités agricoles
mais le modèle la culture l'identité
agricole telle que c'était construite
depuis des siècles parce que le
dérèglement climatique il est c'est ce
que disent en tout cas les spécialistes
c'est un degré c'est 500 km de décalage
de climat
théorique à l'échelle d'une génération
où à l'échelle de deux générations et
donc ça doit nous interroger et donc ça
cette interroge profondément le monde
agricole mais ça doit nous interroger
nous aussi parce que ça remet en cause
nos espaces nous identités nos
productions de traditions et il faut
qu'on y travaille évidemment et puis
l'agriculture elle a besoin de
travailler sur le temps long dans ce
monde qui est irrémédiablement et pour
l'instant mais nous sommes c'est ce que
je disais en début de mon propos des
artisans du temps long et de la pensée
longue et l'agriculture elle a besoin
aussi qu'on la pense dans le dans le
temps long et je voudrais dire un mot
dans ce dans ce moment-là du paradoxe
que nous vivons nous sommes dans une
société vis-à-vis de l'agriculture mais
vis-à-vis finalement de tous les sujets
du monde nous sommes sociétés qui qui a
dû qui prône la
différenciation la différence le respect
de l'autre et qui à longueur de journée
a du mal à vivre avec la différence
je suis très frappé de ça en permanence
parce que ça me faisait une société qui
vit la différence non pas comme une
richesse comme nous nous la vivons comme
nous l'avons toujours vécu au modem avec
François mais qui vit la différence
comme une violence qui vit la différence
comme une remise en cause personnelle
qui vise et qui fait que qui pense le
respect comme le respect de soi-même
mais pas le respect forcément de l'autre
et nous avons besoin de construire une
société qui accepte la différence par la
sienne mais qui accepte la différence
dans de l'autre parce que pour moi c'est
un enrichissement
et la majorité doit respecter les
minorités les minorités doivent
respecter les minorités et les minorités
doivent aussi respecter les majorités
c'est ça le respect de la différence et
la bienveillance
et nous ne sommes pas les moins armés
François et vous tous chers amis pour
pour être ceux qui sont respectueux de
la différence et de la volonté de
réconcilier ne suffit pas d'ailleurs on
dit souvent d'avoir raison
il suffit pas d'avoir raison en avance
il faut aussi réussir à convaincre et
embarquer les gens il faut qu'on fixe
des repères pour chercher à comprendre
et chercher à se comprendre et c'est
bien le travail que nous avons devant
nous et je voudrais vous dire juste en
quelques mots
remerciement au début et remerciements à
la fin la fierté qui est la mienne
d'adresser des remerciements à plusieurs
d'entre vous nominativement et à
collectivement vous dire un certain
nombre de choses la première c'est
saluer les anciens et les nouveaux au
combattants de la première heure et à
ceux qui nous ont rejoint à ceux qui
sont partis et à ceux qui nous ont
rejoint après qui sont revenus parce que
je trouve que c'est un très beau aux
militant de toujours et aux militants du
jour à ceux qui n'ont jamais fait défaut
qui n'ont jamais douté y compris dans
les temps les plus difficiles je
voudrais me rappeler aussi qu'en 2010
sur l'intuition de Marielle et avec
François il nous avait dit il faut faire
émerger une nouvelle génération
on avait appelé ça les quads
les quadras sont devenus quinquas mais
pas tous mais parce qu'ils étaient
trentenaire à l'époque
mais je voudrais sincèrement merci
toutes celles et ceux François au
premier chef évidemment Marielle à qui
je pense Jacqueline va tous ceux qui ont
pensé que la le destin d'information
politique c'était la volonté réelle
sincère de faire monter une génération
j'en suis je n'en suis pas le témoin
unique j'en vois plein dans la salle qui
sont le témoin de cette génération qui a
émergé depuis 10 ans et c'est très rare
dans la vie politique de faire émerger
comme ça une solidité une solidarité et
en même temps de faire émerger une
génération
vous dire donc là la fierté de notre
solidarité la fierté de notre solidité
la fierté d'être resté nous-mêmes et
fidèle à nous-mêmes et le choix
déterminé que nous avons toujours fait
qui est celui de la réconciliation je le
disais tout à l'heure ce sont pour moi
des armes redoutables dans les temps qui
viennent alors dans ces temps un peu
sombre j'aurais tendance à dire d'abord
de ne pas avoir peur des temps qui
viennent et de nous tenir prêts comme
nous nous sommes tenir tenus toujours
prêt au combat et apporter nos idées
parce que notre pays le pas le point
armé pour faire face en tant aux
tempêtes il l'a déjà fait il faut nous
tenir prêt enfin parce que ne sachant ni
le moment ni l'heure des combats que
nous aurons amenés non pas les combats
des tensions n'ont pas leur des
collapsologues et des théoriciens du
chaos mais lors de ceux qui ont toujours
été là pour tracer un chemin
pour lutter contre les extrêmes et qui
inlassablement ont été prêts à repartir
au combat et à remettre en jeu la
capacité que nous avons nous à nous
remettre en jeu en permanence c'est une
grande force dans la vie politique et je
le dis que parce que je disais comme je
disais tout à l'heure c'est pas parce
que nous sommes en situation de
gouvernement qu'il faut pas en
permanence s'interroger sur la capacité
à remettre en jeu les choses si nous
nous serions des fois notre rôle et dont
je voudrais simplement vous remercier
toutes et tous d'être là d'être là au
premier sens du terme d'être là solide
d'être là debout d'être là libre et je
vous remercie François d'être là debout
solide et libre et d'avoir porté cette
parole depuis un paquet d'années à toi
François